seems like Justin Bieber is no longer
hashtag team yay I'm just extremely
happy can you tell by my face
a source sells E.T Justin is quote
distancing himself from Kanye after he
threw shade toward his wife Haley Bieber
saying quote he has been a true friend
to Kanye and tried to empathize with him
in the past but this crossed the line
that he is not okay with if your core
Foundation isn't supporting you then
you're just gonna
you're just not going to be balanced I
think that that's it just shows how much
I care here's a breakdown of how Haley
got pulled into Kanye's drama last week
he criticized Vogue editor Gabriella
karifa Johnson Styles after she slammed
his white lives Matter t-shirts and soon
after Haley shared a message on her
Instagram in support of Gabriella
writing quote my respect for you runs
deep my friend to know you is to adore
you and to work with you is an honor
Kanye then went after Haley and has
since deleted post on Instagram with
claims that she got a nose job and even
dated Drake a store sells ET quote
Justin is very protective over Haley and
he is upset by Kanye's attack on her
where he said hurtful and untrue things
I think just being kind at the end of
the day is what
separates you from others because
there's so many people I see in this
industry that Thrive and do amazing and
some of them are talented and some of
them aren't but you end up walking away
with in situations liking the people who
are were nice too rather than the people
who are more successful and for Justin
quote being there for Haley and
supporting his wife is his main priority
and he's doing that
we worked very hard to like be in the
space that we're in now and like
trusting each other Justin and Haley's
Bond seems to be stronger than ever
after they recently celebrated their
four-year anniversary last month he's my
best friend I love coming home to him
like we're busy people and we want to be
in a marriage so we're making it work
the couple's wedding vows were put to
the test this year after both Stars
experienced Health scares in March Haley
suffered a blood clot to her brain
definitely the scariest moment of my
life basically it's like having a mini
stroke and three months later Justin
revealed he was experiencing facial
paralysis and have been diagnosed with
Ramsay Hunt Syndrome despite their
struggles A source told ET that quote
they are closer than ever and the best
part about that relationship is that
they don't have to try and make it work
it's an amazing feeling it's something
Haley echoed during her appearance on
Good Morning America in June I think the
silver lining of it honestly is that it
brings us a lot closer because you're
going through this together you're being
there for each other you're supporting
each other and there's just something
that really like bonds you through
through these times
[Music]